do you think uh
from a historical perspective hitler
could have been stopped
from within germany if and or from
outside
or this
well depends on who you want to focus
whether you want to focus on stalin or
hitler but he feels like hitler was the
one
as a political movement that could have
been stopped
i think that uh
the point was that a lot of people
wanted hitler so he got support from a
lot of quarters it was a number of
industrialists who supported him because
they thought that the democracy is
obviously not working and unstable and
you need a strong man
and he was willing to play that part
there were also people in the us who
thought that hitler would stop uh stalin
and uh would act as a balrack against uh
bolshevism
which he probably would have done right
but uh at which cost
and then many of the things that he was
going to do like the holocaust
was
something where people thought this is
rhetoric he's not actually going to do
this right especially many of the jews
themselves which were humanists and for
them this was outside of the scope that
was thinkable right
i mean i i i wonder
if hitler is uniquely
i i want to carefully use this term but
uniquely evil
so if hitler was never born
if somebody else would come in this
place so like
just
thinking about the progress of history
how important are those singular figures
that
that lead to mass destruction and
cruelty
because
my senses
hitler was unique
the
it wasn't just about the environment and
the context that gave him
like
like another person would not come in
his place to do as destructive of the
things that he did
there was a combination of uh charisma
of madness of
psychopathy of just uh ego all those
things which are very unlikely to come
together in one person in the right time
it also depends on the context of the
country that you're operating in
if you uh tell
the germans that they have a historical
destiny uh
in this romantic country the effect is
probably different than it is in other
countries
but the uh
stalin has killed a few more people than
hitler did and if you look at the
probability that you're survived under
stalin
right uh hitler killed people if
they if he thought they were not worth
living or if they were harmful to his
racist project right he basically felt
that the jews would be too cosmopolitan
and would not be willing to uh
participate in the racist redefinition
of society and the value of society and
an israel state in this way that as he
wanted it to have it so they he saw them
as
a
harmful danger especially since they
played such an important role in the
economy and culture of germany
and
it so we had basically had some radical
but rational reason to murder them and
stalin just killed everyone
basically the stalinist purges were such
a random thing where he said that
there's a
certain possibility that this particular
part of the population as a number of
german collaborators or something and we
just kill them all yeah right well if
you look at what mao did the number of
uh people that were killed absolutely in
absolute numbers were much higher under
mao that they were under stalin
so it's super hard to say the the the
other thing is that you uh look at
jinger's khan and so on how many people
he killed
where do you see there are a number of
of things that happen in human history
that actually really put a substantial
dent in the existing population or
napoleon
and
it's it's very difficult to eventually
measure it because what's happening is
basically evolution
on a human scale
where one monkey figures out a way to
become viral
and uh is
using this viral technology to change
the patterns of society at the very very
large scale
and what we find so abhorrent about
these changes is the complexity that is
being destroyed by this that it's
basically like a big fire that burns out
a lot of the existing culture and
structure that existed before
yeah and and it all just starts with one
monkey
one one cares madagape and there's a
bunch of them throughout history yeah
but it's in a given environment it's
basically similar to wildfires in
california right the temperature is
rising
uh there is less rain falling
and then suddenly a single spark can
have an effect that in other times would
be contained
you